many have come to this ferry terminal
eager to leave bangladesh's capital they
want to return to their home villages
before a new coronavirus lockdown takes
effect on thursday
with the public intercity transportation
already suspended
some have squeezed into auto rickshaws
hopped onto motorbikes
and even hired ambulances to take them
home khadiza begum and their family
members like many others here
are stranded next to highway unable to
find any transport
angari we've been waiting here for
several hours
but can't find any transport we live
nearby but had to walk all the way here
we came to visit our relatives but now
we're not sure how we'll get back to
madrid
the ferries were packed with hundreds of
people ignoring health and safety
protocols
tens of thousands of people crossed into
south and southwestern bangladesh
through this very terminal 40 mile
outskirt of dhaka it's known as shimulia
terminal
now there are many other terminals where
people are still crossing
many who are leaving the capital are
migrant workers and daily wage earners
they can't stay in the city during the
lockdown because they have no way of
making a living
we are leaving because everything is
shutting down here and there's hardly
any work
i have a family it's much cheaper to
manage ourselves in the village than in
dhaka
which is why we took the decision
health authorities fear that
overcrowding in fairy terminals could
worsen the spread of the virus
we came to dhaka with a patient to
consult for the doctor here
now since everything is shutting down
here we decided to rush back home
with many difficulties hospitals across
bangladesh
are been overwhelmed with new kovid 19
cases and the daily deaths have more
than doubled
health experts are alarmed by the
sergeant infections
it is spread now all over the country
more than
50 districts are like but in danger
uh more than 10 percent infectivity all
over the country
and some of the like 20 districts are
having 20 plus uh infection rate in the
country
and it is coming back to taka also
it is increasing in dhaka so overall
situation is
is alarming the government has deployed
the army along with border guards and
other security forces
to enforce a strict shutdown in phases
starting on monday
many health officials have been critical
of its recent handling of the pandemic
which has been fueled by the delta
variant now they worry
the situation could get worse if the new
measures are not properly enforced
sandwich al jazeera mawa bangladesh